vous avez fait exploser mon tél avec
l'histoire de Casta mon père mes
beaux-parents toute la famille donc je
suis obligé de faire un droit de réponse
donc il y a quelques années
effectivement
Benjamin Castaldi un petit peu draguer
donc déjà le gars me drague mais ne se
rappelle plus de mon nom donc je ne
m'appelle pas mood la liste Benjamin je
m'appelle Yasmine ougliss il dit que
j'ai fait un peu de télé donc bah ouais
je suis tous les matins dans Les
Maternelles sur France 2 donc on peut
dire que que j'ai fait un peu de télé
voilà donc la Story c'est quoi la Story
c'est que donc fin 2009 avant que je
rencontre mon mari je précise il m'a
dragué il m'a envoyé quelques bouquets
de fleurs à l'époque il a même voulu
m'envoyer son hélico pour qu'on aille
dîner un soir et ce qu'il oublie de vous
dire c'est la raison pour laquelle j'y
suis pas allée donc peut-être parce
qu'il me plaisait pas déjà mais il y
avait une autre raison je vous laisse
deviner
j'aimerais qu'on reprenne après l'hélico
parce que je veux le calme écouter après
l'hélico reprenez
à l'hélico
mon père mes beaux-parents toute la
famille donc je suis obligé de faire un
droit de réponse donc il y a quelques
années effectivement
Benjamin Castaldi un petit peu draguer
donc déjà le gars me drague il ne se
rappelle plus de mon nom donc je ne
m'appelle pas Mouglalis Benjamin je
m'appelle Yasmine ougliss il dit que
j'ai fait un peu de télé donc bah ouais
je suis tous les matins dans Les
Maternelles sur France 2 donc on peut
dire que que j'ai fait un peu de télé
voilà donc la Story c'est quoi la Story
c'est que donc fin 2009 avant que je
rencontre mon mari je précise il m'a
dragué il m'a envoyé quelques bouquets
de fleurs à l'époque il a même voulu
m'envoyer son hélico pour qu'on aille
dîner un soir et ce qu'il oublie de vous
dire c'est la raison pour laquelle j'y
suis pas allée donc peut-être parce
qu'il me plaisait pas déjà mais il y
avait une autre raison je vous laisse
deviner
[Applaudissements]
chacun va proposer ah oui la raison à
son avis pour laquelle il ne pouvait pas
il ne pouvait pas le voir on va démarrer
par vous à mon avis c'est qu'elle avait
peur qu'il pète dans l'hélicoptère
[Applaudissements]
j'ai le même problème avec des potes un
peu comme ça il sort parfois la vanne
qu'il faut pas sortir c'est le problème
voilà il est et voilà c'est son problème
donc va faire un tour
je peux plus libérer non mais c'est
insupportable oui je dis vraiment le
fond de ma pensée même si ça s'appelle à
mon avis c'est une jeune femme très bien
et Benjamin était peut-être déjà aussi
en main et elle a pas voulu être la
maîtresse
tout ça
pour moi il est pour moi il y a pas été
parce qu'il était déjà en couple elle a
dit aussi qu'il fallait pas que ça oui
parce que Bernard on est là non
il est là
j'ai changé d'avis elle lui a dit
qu'elle lui plaisait pas mais qui avait
une autre raison ça serait qu'il est
l'autre raison ce serait qu'il était
alors je pense qu'il était en couple et
l'affaire est très grave
Daniel non ça me semble une évidence
elle a entendu dire qu'il avait un trop
petit zizi
[Applaudissements]
et c'est un grand tour c'est un grand
grand tour
ça suffira on va se débarrasser de toi
c'est de la calomnie tout ça moi je suis
avec Benjamin je pense qu'il est pas du
tout comme ça elle devait partir au ski
et c'est pour ça qu'elle a annulé parce
qu'elle avait un séjour au ski tu sors
c'est nul
[Applaudissements]
c'est nul oui non moi je veux pas du
tout accablé Benjamin je pense qu'il
était juste marié jusqu'au cou
bravo Géraldine tu restes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un gros bâtard j'avais une meuf à
l'époque
vous étiez où tous les deux
une autre histoire amuse-toi j'ai tout
le dossier
et je l'adore et je l'adore voilà donc
non voilà donc c'est non bravo
pour envoyer un bateau
c'est pas mal j'avais oublié c'est le
coup d'hélicoptère
incroyable tu m'étonnes qui sont ruinées
de Paris à la campagne ta campagne
[Applaudissements]
tu voulais ramener des meufs
[Musique]
j'ai tu me le dire s'il te plaît d'où
partait l'hélicoptère et où aller
l'hélicoptère Benjamin s'il te plaît
alors allez la chercher où d'entendre
dans ton milieu
Porte de Versailles et où aller
l'hélicoptère Trouville
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais oublié donc on n'a pas oublié
l'hôtel ou pas mais j'étais une maison
là-bas
[Rires]
tu es ignoble
[Applaudissements]
si j'étais toi je me Terrisse non mais
franchement si j'étais toi je me tirais
de toi propre
c'est une question technique je connais
pas bien le vol d'hélicoptère
l'hélicoptère qui arrive donc le soir à
Trouville peut-il redécoller de nuit
qualification aux instruments ou pas si
on peut pas voler de nuit on ne décolle
pas mais quand on a les la bonne calife
on peut décoller et celui-là pouvait
redécoller tout à fait
s'en souvenais plus l'hélico
Benjamin une seule fois dans sa vie il a
failli faire une bêtise